but Georgia couple says they are being
held hostage in a Mexican Hospital
Steven Johnson went into diabetic shock
while on vacation in Mexico with his
fiancee doctors helped him recover but
now the couple says the hospital won't
let them leave here's mark Strassmann I
still feel like a captive now because I
can't leave Steven Johnson talked to us
from the Mexican hospital room where he
feels trapped
Johnson dead his fiance Tori Austin were
on a cruise he collapsed suddenly from
diabetic shock and was in danger of
dying at a hospital in Progresso Mexico
a team of doctors dialysis and a
ventilator helped him recover but when
he tried to leave he says his hospital
became a prison punch it because I was
scared the hospital wanted its money
first $14,000 paid in full Johnson had
no health insurance they refused his
offer to pay in installments
hospital staff physically blocked them
from leaving several times once with a
trashcan lid
donors stepped in the big one movie
mogul Tyler Perry he heard about
Johnson's story and agreed to settle his
bill oh my life I hope I get to meet him
when I get back to Atlanta because he
deserves the biggest hug but Johnson
will now have to wait even longer the
hospital says he's not well enough to
travel
the US State Department is aware of
Johnson's case and a Department official
is now trying to help up a couple even
if Johnson did have health insurance he
might be in the same predicament most
major health plan providers don't cover
medical care outside the US and an
option that's often recommended is
travel medical insurance for CBS this
morning Saturday mark Strassmann atlanta
sounds like his bill will be racked up
even higher yeah right because he can't
they don't want him to leave that's the
nightmare though being in a foreign
country not being able to leave
especially if he really isn't well
enough to you know something to think
about before you travel